bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
le socialisme peut-il encore faire rêver
vous y croyez Arthur de la porte merci
d'être avec nous député PS du Calvados
votre manifeste pour un socialisme
joyeux aux Éditions de l'Aube en
témoignent à une condition que le parti
retrouve sa tradition festive la joie
comme force politique en voilà une drôle
d'idée on en parle tous les deux dans la
deuxième partie tout à l'heure notre
grand débat ce soir où sont passés les
économies le budget 2024 présenté hier à
qui l'oublier les déficits publics 3000
milliards de dettes des taux d'intérêt
qui s'envolent combien de temps cette
situation est-elle tenable économie
transition inflation l'équation
budgétaire impossible nous en débattons
avec mes invités dans un tout petit
instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir il y a une Goose pour
son parti pris politique le mot de la
semaine de Mariette darrigan et puis
Bourbon Express histoire de de jour à
l'Assemblée présentait ce soir par Marco
pommier voilà pour le programme on y va
Arthur de la porte ça vous regarde c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est donc un numéro d'équilibriste pour
éviter l'austérité et en même temps
tenir le cap des comptes publics Bruno
Le Maire a présenté son budget 2024 hier
à peine annoncé son plan d'économie et
déjà sous le feu des critiques le
ministre des Finances aurait-il renoncé
à réduire les déficits publics bonsoir
Alexandre Roy et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance des Français qui
sont établis dans plusieurs pays
d'Europe du Nord on va pas tous les
citer évidemment il y a le Royaume-Uni
vous êtes membre de la commission des
finances tout comme vous Patrick etsel
bonsoir merci d'être là député les
républicains du Bas-Rhin bonsoir
François et calle bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir de vous retrouver dans cette
émission vous êtes l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes des finances publiques
conseillés à la Cour des comptes et
président de FIP Eco enfin bonsoir
marvinho bonsoir bienvenue journaliste
économique à l'opinion il faut expliquer
quand même que votre article en Une de
votre quotidien nous a inspiré le débat
de ce soir budget 2024 capitulation
sur les économies on va y revenir
évidemment Arthur de Laporte vous êtes
parti prenante évidemment on a envie de
savoir ce que veut faire la gauche pour
trouver des économies dans ce budget
allez elles sont où ces économies les
choix budgétaires pour 2024 on voit ça
tout de suite dans le chrono de Blacko
qu'on aille tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam et
bonsoir messieurs d'habitude j'y pense
fort à toutes et tous mais alors ce
budget alors vous souvenez sans doute
que avant l'été Bruno la maire l'avait
dit répéter sa priorité pour le budget
2024 ce serait de réduire l'endettement
d'ailleurs vous voyez accélération du
honnêtement c'était son slogan du coup
on découvre le projet de budget 2024 on
est comment dire un peu étonné de
constater que l'année prochaine la
France va emprunter 285 milliards
d'euros et qu'en fait c'est un record
historique alors moi je dis étonné mais
il y en a qui sont carrément inquiets ce
sont les LR qui se sont exprimés parce
que cette certes le gouvernement prévoit
quand même 16 milliards d'économies
l'année prochaine mais pas des coupes
dans les dépenses non en fait c'est
simplement la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
et donc il y a 14 milliards d'aide sur
l'énergie qui sont amenés à disparaître
en fait selon Olivier Marleix qui était
ce matin sur Sud Radio le président
Macron aurait raté le coche c'est à dire
que il aurait dû profiter de cette
période où les taux d'intérêt étaient
très bas pour des endetter la France on
on est le seul pays d'Europe avoir fait
ce calcul cynique tous les autres ont
profité des taux d'intérêt négatifs pour
se désendetter et aujourd'hui on est le
pays d'Europe qui est dans la situation
la plus catastrophique financièrement
alors
là où Olivier a raison c'est
qu'effectivement la France est le
mauvais élève de l'Europe en terme
d'endettement puisque pour le déficit
par exemple le déficit est à 4,4% du PIB
alors qu'en Allemagne ils sont à 1,2%
mais en même temps comme dirait l'autre
si on prend le dynamisme de l'économie
la France sentir plutôt pas mal puisque
nous avons 1% de croissance ce qui est
pas énorme mais c'est toujours mieux que
l'Allemagne qui elle de son côté
visé par une récession enfin sera sans
doute en rester sur alors bien sûr quand
on parle de théories économique ça peut
paraître de vertueux de dépenser moins
on appelle ça une politique d'austérité
d'ailleurs après la crise de 2008
c'était le FMI qui avait militait pour
qu'on mette en place une politique
d'austérité pour sortir de la crise sauf
que 5 ans plus tard ils avaient mis à
cool pas ils avaient ah non c'est une
erreur qu'on a dit faite en prenant
l'austérité donc forcément pour Thomas
Cazenave le ministre des comptes publics
ben voilà c'est un argument tout trouvé
moi je crois pas au cure d'austérité on
coupe dans les services publics on
augmente les impôts il y a eu des
erreurs qui ont été faites en 2008 qui
nous ont amené dans le mur on assume un
redressement progressif et comment vous
progressif de notre de nos finances
publiques de notre déficit public et de
notre dette alors voyez le ministre des
comptes publics n'a pas l'air de
s'inquiéter il est relativement
optimiste et son optimisme n'est pas
partagé par tous loin de là regardez le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques mais
aussi la Banque de France en fait la
plupart des experts trouvent que ce
budget n'est pas crédible parce que il
repose sur des optimistes des prévisions
pardon beaucoup trop optimistes pour
l'année prochaine le gouvernement peut
quand même se défendre en disant ah
écoutez l'année dernière nous avait déjà
fait le coup la Banque de France vous
avez dit attention récession 2023 et
finalement ils ont dû corriger donc ils
avaient fait une erreur puisque il y a
eu 1% de croissance à peu près comme
l'avait prévu le gouvernement alors
attention je sais qu'il est temps de
conclure on ne peut pas non plus de
oublier de dire que la seule solution
pour faire l'écrit pour des budget n'est
pas de couper dans les dépenses on peut
aussi augmenter les impôts évidemment de
la réponse du gouvernement vous la
connaissez c'est la statistique de
l'Insee qui dit que la France est parmi
les pays où il y a déjà les prélèvements
obligatoires les plus importants donc
pas question pour le gouvernement
d'augmenter les impôts les places au
débat parce que même si le budget est
voté au 49-3 bah ce soir on a le droit
d'en débattre absolument et comment
merci beaucoup Stéphane blackowski
Alexandre pourquoi ne pas dire
clairement la situation économique est
très compliquée vous voulez aider le
pouvoir d'achat des Français vous voulez
accompagner financer la transition
écologique vous ne voulez pas augmenter
les impôts donc vous renoncez à réduire
vraiment les déficits pourquoi ne pas le
dire et l'assumer
non je pense pas que c'est le cas je
pense que vous avez remarquablement
présenté le sujet au début c'est un
budget d'équilibre entre des priorités
différentes il y a évidemment un besoin
d'accompagner les Français face à
l'inflation et j'aime pas du tout
l'expression lutter contre l'inflation
parce que ce n'est pas de la lutte
contre l'inflation c'est on accompagne
les Français face à des effets de
l'inflation l'inflation c'est pas
quelque chose que l'État peut effacer
c'est quelque chose qui existe dans
l'économie on ne peut pas l'effacer on
peut choisir la Wii touche qui touche on
peut essayer de l'étaler sur le temps
etc mais on ne peut pas l'effacer on
veut aider les Français dans ce temps-là
il y a plusieurs dispositifs dans ce
budget qui le font on veut en même temps
des comptes publics a dit très
clairement réduire le défi public mais
de façon progressive parce qu'on sait
que si on le fait brutalement sera
heurtra nos perspectives de croissance
économique on vient de voter la loi de
programmation publique c'est quand même
ramené à 3%. c'est ça et on veut
investir
2027 et ont investir et je pense que là
il faut être précis la réalité quand je
reprends les commentaires
c'est que c'est factuellement faux la
France et ce gouvernement enfin la
majorité précédente ont commencé de les
endettements de la France entre 2017 et
2020 on est sorti de la procédure pour
déficit excessifs et c'était la période
où il y avait des taux très bas ensuite
sur des suivis deux périodes très
particulières une première du covid ou
tout le monde sait à peu près mis
d'accord et à mon avis c'était la bonne
solution pour aider les entreprises pour
aider les collectivités pour aider les
ménages dans cette crise terrible avec
une relance à la sortie qui nous assure
des résultats économiques meilleurs
aujourd'hui que nos voisins très
clairement c'est d'ailleurs les titres
de tous les journaux allemands en ce
moment et après la guerre en Ukraine
avec l'inflation où on a à nouveau fait
le choix de protéger les Français mais
je veux dire ici très clairement il n'y
a pas l'ombre d'un doute dans mon esprit
qu'il faut désormais la France et que
graduellement alors faut maintenir et
tenir nos déficits l'essentiel Stéphane
l'a dit des économies réside dans
l'arrêt du bouclier tarifaire sur
l'énergie c'est à peu près 12 à 14
milliards d'euros c'est ça 14 milliards
d'euros concrètement ça ça veut dire que
ça va tenir toute l'année on sait que le
prix du baril peut augmenter on sait que
l'hiver il peut faire très très froid
vous dites ce soir ça bougera pas ce
bouclier c'est fini absolument et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un dispositif qui est
proposé pour aider les travailleurs qui
utilisent la voiture parce que ce
dispositif est la générosité des
dispositifs de crise c'est qui concerne
tout le monde de façon totalement
indiscriminer c'est à dire que le
bouclier est tarifaire que vous ayez des
moyens que vous n'en ayez pas que vous
ayez une voiture que vous n'en ayez pas
vous êtes protégé par le bouclier
tarifaire électricité gaz et et par les
mesures de ristourne du pétrole
aujourd'hui on veut changer de système
pour aller accompagner ce qu'on a le
plus besoin c'est pour ça que le
président euros a annoncé une mesure qui
a justement vocation à aider je reviens
on ne peut pas lutter contre le fait que
le prix du barol augmente on peut aider
les Français qui sont plus exposés à
cette augmentation justement ce budget
il accompagne ceux qui sont touchés le
plus durement par cette inflex alors la
question c'est où est-ce qu'elles sont
les économies à part ce bouclier
tarifaire marvinho vous avez utilisé un
mot quand même très fort en une
j'imagine que vous l'assumez pleinement
vous dites le gouvernement capitule vous
suivez Bruno Le Maire à Bercy on voit
bien qu'il a un peu changé d'avis
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé exactement
c'est effectivement ce qui est frappant
c'est que le 19 juin à Bercy Bruno Le
Maire convoque tous les acteurs de la
dépense publique on voit que la presse
et dit voilà le résultat de mes revues
de dépenses je vais faire des tas
d'économies avec des mesures finalement
assez dures je vais re-répartir la
charge entre l'État les ménages et les
entreprises par exemple je vais
augmenter le nombre de jours de carence
en cas d'arrêt maladie ce ne sera plus
la sécurité sociale qui va les
rembourser mais ça sera aux entreprises
de prendre en charge je vais augmenter
le prix sur des boîtes de médicaments le
reste à charge pour les pour les assurer
qu'il n'est pas remboursé par la
Sécurité Sociale et là on arrive à Bercy
le budget est présenté et on nous dit ah
non finalement toutes ces mesures on ne
va pas les prendre on ne va on va se
contenter de faire des mesures
d'économies qui sont bien réelles qui
sont débranchés le bouclier c'est pas si
facile de débrancher le bouclier ça veut
dire que le le prix de l'électricité va
augmenter mais en tout cas par rapport à
la connaître le véritable prix de
l'énergie alors un peu plus parce qu'il
y aura quand même des aides sur le prix
d'électricité mais par rapport à ce qui
nous avait dit on a besoin de faire des
économies on a besoin de sortir du quoi
qu'il en coûte maintenant on doit
redresser les comptes il avait été très
solennel et ben par rapport à ce
discours là il y a un décalage et on est
obligé de le noter nous commentateurs ça
veut dire que il a d'autres méthodes
pour réduire le déficit il va s'appuyer
sur la croissance qui est qui puisqu'il
a pris une prévision assez optimiste
toute la question c'est est-ce que cette
prévision de croissance est crédible
alors c'est 1% et puis alors 1% en 2023
et 1,4 % en 2024
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'entre temps
le gouvernement s'est rendu compte que
sa prévision de croissance il
l'atteindrait en 2023 ce qui fait une
meilleure base à la fin de l'année pour
partir sur 2024 et donc il s'est dit bah
il y a pas besoin de faire toutes les
mesures qu'on avait prévues pour arriver
à la même cible de déficit puisqu'il est
Réda le déficit autant en tout cas
officiellement sur le papier à 4,4%
contre 4,7 4,9 cette année donc voilà le
déficit sur le papier il va se réduire
si la prévision de croissance est
atteinte grâce à des recettes fiscales
qui rentrent avec l'installation et la
croissance ça fait beaucoup de si
Patrick
elle est très très difficile cette
situation économique franchement
personne voilà bah forcément envie
d'être à la place du gouvernement
aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est du
Mikado
politique c'est un peu la place du
gouvernement vous feriez mieux
franchement est-ce que vous comprenez
cet exercice d'équilibriste alors ce que
je ne comprends absolument pas c'est la
manière dont se comporte Monsieur le
Maire je voudrais rappeler ici que un
ministre de l'économie et des finances
il doit
inspirer de la confiance et donc il doit
être crédible c'est-à-dire qu'il doit y
avoir une cohérence totale entre ce
qu'il dit et ce qu'il fait or monsieur V
vient de le dire et je trouve que cet
article de l'opinion et et très enfin il
est très vrai il est très factuel il
montre que là il y a une difficulté
majeure parce que le ministre lui-même
ne tient pas ses propres engagements et
en fait ça c'est terrible parce que ça
risque de fragiliser notre pays et je
voudrais surtout insister sur le fait
que nous sommes dans une situation où la
Commission européenne a indiqué très
clairement qu'à partir du 31 décembre
prochain les exceptions aux critères
maastrichiens c'est-à-dire une dette qui
ne devait pas être supérieur enfin
pouvait être supérieur en raison des
exceptions à 3% du PIB et bien ce sera
fini et là ce qui risque de se passer à
partir de là c'est que un moment donné
les marchés financiers peuvent réagir
dans votre reportage se dit ça veut dire
quoi ça une attaque sur la dette une
dégradation de la note ça veut dire très
clairement que ce risque là est lorsque
en plus de ça sur les marchés il va
falloir chercher 285 milliards le fameux
spread c'est à dire les écarts de taux
par exemple entre l'Allemagne et la
France pour le moment ils sont très
faibles mais comme les autres pays
européens font mieux que nous et sont
dans une situation où ils peuvent cette
fois-ci être en dessous de cette barre
des 3%, le risque c'est que les taux
d'intérêt spécifiquement pour la France
soit plus intérêt plus important que
pour d'autres perruques européens et
qu'à partir de là les taux d'intérêt
liés à notre dette augmente et on voit
bien que là il y a un risque réel
d'ailleurs le le président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques Pierre
Moscovici hier en commission des
finances lui-même indiqué qu'il y avait
là une situation extrêmement risquée
avec deux surcroît une prévision
beaucoup trop optimiste par rapport à la
réalité c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné il a il a indiqué que comment dire
la probabilité d'atteindre ce que le
gouvernement nous met sur le papier est
quasi nul donc voilà
on va le lire justement le premier
président de la Cour des comptes il est
assez cinglant François et qu'elle c'est
vrai il l'a dit à l'Assemblée nationale
en commission des finances il dit dans
l'Express si on ne fait rien l'explosion
de l'endettement va paralyser l'action
publique virgule l'étrangler on ne fait
rien François ECAL alors on ne fait pas
rien on essaye de faire des choses mais
c'est extrêmement difficile le contexte
actuel le gouvernement a une stratégie
qui consiste à essayer de réduire le
déficit public et finalement la date
sans augmenter les impôts en arrêtant de
les baisser ou en reportant les baisses
ce qui suppose même avec des prévisions
de croissance optimistes en effet de
réaliser des économies qui n'ont jamais
été réalisés jusqu'à présent jamais
on en a fait quand même des efforts
d'économie pas beaucoup pas assez mais
en 2024 il y a 1,5 milliards bien lu ce
budget d'économie par excepté le la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte sur l'énergie
alors là
je parlais en fait de sa fin de cette
trajectoire jusqu'à 2027 donc c'est vrai
exactement voilà après en 202 le
problème en effet c'est que sur 2024 on
ne les voit pas encore on voit en effet
que des économies si mais sur les
mesures alors parce qu'il faut les
appeler d'urgence de soutien de
l'activité enfin voilà qui ont été
prises pendant la crise en particulier
celles qui ont été prises pour faire
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
donc déjà ça va pas être facile déjà moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord que lorsque
le gouvernement dit qu'on va essayer de
remplacer ça par une prime forfaitaire
en fonction des revenus ciblés sur ce
qui ont besoin de leurs voitures
que ce qu'on faisait jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire des boucliers des boucliers
qui profit qu'est-ce qu'on risque
exactement pour bien comprendre
dans le contexte actuel il faut quand
même avoir en tête que le gouvernement a
autour de lui et à l'Assemblée nationale
des gens qui continuent à proposer à
venir aux Français la solution pour ça
c'est de baisser durablement les taxes
c'est de baisser la TVA là ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher
on entend ce discours à gauche sur sur
l'Impôt sur sur la TVA sur les taxes pas
vous la TVA pas aux parties socialiste
avant de nous dire
où vont les économies si la gauche
envers viendra aux solutions après
est-ce que pour vous cette question là
déjà déficit c'est une priorité pour le
parti pour présenter c'est que on peut
pas
responsablement diriger un état sans se
poser la question d'un équilibre entre
des dépenses et des recettes sinon on va
dans le mur sinon on peut avoir une
spirale de la dette et ça peut être
extrêmement compliqué on l'a pendant la
crise des dettes souveraines mais le
sujet là c'est à la fois la question de
comment on arrive à garantir on va dire
une certaine sécurité mais aussi comment
on arrive à ne pas plomber la croissance
et le sujet il est là parce que si on
plombe la croissance on l'a bien vu
c'est comme ça que derrière on a plus de
recettes pour l'État c'est comme ça que
le déficit se creuse et malheureusement
ou heureusement la consommation
intérieure vous reconnaissez que le
gouvernement fait pas ce choix il réduit
pas drastiquement les services publics
les fonctions et il fait des mauvais
choix mais ça je vais je vais y revenir
la consommation intérieure c'est 60% de
la croissance ça veut dire que quand on
plombe les ménages et bien derrière la
croissance et le chute et donc il y a
une responsabilité du côté du
gouvernement qui est de la manière dont
on soutient cette consommation dont on
soutient les ménages et il y a un sujet
comment on fait pour que les ménages
continuent de consommer comment on fait
pour continuer de la croissance et
comment on fait pour continuer à avoir
des recettes pour l'État et bah c'est la
question des salaires et aujourd'hui on
a l'impression que le gouvernement élu
totalement la question des salaires qui
commence
à faire à peu près deux ans qu'on
demande la question de la revalorisation
des salaires qu'on demande une
revalorisation supérieure du SMIC et
plus largement de l'ensemble des
salaires et une récréation supérieure du
point d'indice bref c'est des choses qui
sont importantes aujourd'hui les
salariés ils crient famille c'est
littéralement ça il consomme moins et ça
pose problème la solution c'est
évidemment de rehausser les salaires
mais derrière c'est aussi d'avoir des
mesures plus importantes parce que le
Président de la République même s'il dit
qu'il aime la bagnole ce qu'on peut par
ailleurs regretter c'est que il n'a pas
dû faire souvent son plein 100 euros par
mois pour des travailleurs pauvres
uniquement les 50% les plus pauvres
c'est pas suffisant en une fois c'est
100 euros
par mois pour les travailleurs le plus
pauvres c'est qu'il a pas fait cette
version un échec de 100 euros c'est tout
bien plus souvent et éventuellement par
mois et on peut cibler les travailleurs
on peut faire quelque chose de
progressif parce que aujourd'hui grâce
au prélèvement à la source les tailles
connaît les revenus des ménages qui
s'actualise tous les deux mois alors je
vois que vous avez plein de solutions
fiscales de on entend les mots justice
on l'entend pas casser la croissance
avant de vous entendre sur les sur les
solutions où est-ce qu'on pourrait
trouver des économ omies sans
véritablement pénaliser les Français on
va regarder là où vous essayez d'en
trouver alors là c'est pas des
réductions dépenses c'est plutôt de la
rentrée de nouvelles recettes dans les
caisses de l'État Bercy mais en avant un
budget vert avec deux taxes nouvelles
sur les aéroports et sur les autoroutes
attention autour de bâton pour les
usagers regardez c'est signer Baptiste
garguic Chartier
dans le projet de loi de finances
l'exécutif plate pour une taxe de 4,6%
sur les infrastructures de transport et
longs distances autrement dit taxation
des aéroports et des autoroutes en
prévision
elle sera appliquée aux infrastructures
dont les revenus sont supérieurs à 120
millions d'euros et la rentabilité
supérieure à 10% sur ces temps cette
mesure doit rapporter 600 millions
d'euros par an pour financer
l'investissement prévu dans le transport
ferroviaire
mais oui contribution du secteur aérien
oui contribution du secteur autoroutier
les modalités ce sera dans le budget
dans quelques jours moi j'ai pas
l'obsession de la taxe j'ai l'obsession
de la transition écologique un principe
du pollueur-payeur mais chez les
compagnies aériennes ces taxes
cristallisent les tensions ce qui nous
pose problème dans ce projet de loi
c'est que seuls les gros aéroports
seront concernés donc les aéroports
parisiens Roissy Orly les gros aéroports
de province sur lesquels Air France mais
aussi l'ensemble des compagnies
françaises opère majoritairement alors
qu'un aéroport comme Beauvais sur lequel
une low cost étrangère opère ne sera pas
concernée parce que il n'a pas le niveau
d'activité alors cet axe auront-elles
des répercussions sur les consommateurs
les sociétés d'autoroute elles annoncent
déjà la couleur
une hausse des taxes se traduit
inévitablement par une hausse des péages
dixit pierre Coppée président de Vinci
Autoroutes
et pour Bruno Le Maire pas question les
compagnies concessions d'autoroute ne
seront pas autorisées à répercuter les
augmentations de taxes sur les prix des
péages pour l'heure ce n'est qu'un
projet il faudra attendre la validation
officielle du texte dans l'hémicycle
pour la mise en place de cet axes
[Musique]
peut empêcher Vinci de répercuter ces
taxes sur les Français qui les
automobilistes au péage
avant de venir au tac si vous permettez
je veux juste dire deux choses là c'est
on a eu un long débat sur les
perspectives et ce que la cour des
conduit un budget par définition que ce
soit d'un particulier ou d'une famille
ou d'un pays c'est beaucoup de si on a
beaucoup d'hypothèses et on met beaucoup
d'hypothèses on dit l'année prochaine
voilà le taux d'inflation le taux
d'emploi etc la Cour des comptes ce
qu'elle dit c'est que quasiment tous les
si elle est d'accord avec sauf un seul
la croissance ou elle est marginalement
pas d'accord avec il faut juste
croissance
c'est important elle dit vous avez la
bonne présentation vous avez la bonne
prévision en matière donc je pense qu'il
faut il faut utiliser elle dit plausible
elle dit pas c'est la bonne il faut
juste mettre ça et d'ailleurs toutes nos
prévisions depuis 6 ans font presque
systématiquement
il y a toujours des différences sur les
hypothèses mais je pense qu'il faut
faire attention de n'importe quel de
n'importe quel budget la deuxième chose
c'est que il y a des économies dans ce
budget il y a des économies par exemple
sur le Pinel de l'exposition Le Pinel et
que tu es un dispositif qui est très
très inefficace il y a eu des dizaines
de rapports qui montrent qu'il est
efficace en tout cas dans le projet qui
est présenté au Parlement il y a des
dispositifs aujourd'hui qui sont
proposés qui font des économies est-ce
que ce sont des économies à dimension de
la dette française on va se dire les
choses clairement non aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas des économies qui ont sont de
nature à changer profondément la donne
ce qui changera profondément la donne
c'est notre capacité à créer de la
croissance et à faire baisser le taux de
chômage et c'est ce que depuis 6 ans le
pareil nous autres plutôt de Bu 6 ans en
baissant c'est vrai les impôts sur les
particuliers les entreprises on a baissé
les impôts de 60 milliards par contre
ces impôts la plupart d'entre eux ont
des recettes supérieures à ce qu'elles
avaient avec ça
vous avez pas pour que vous baissez et
si vous créez assez d'activité il vous
ramène encore plus d'argent
d'entreprise c'est sa nouvelle l'impôt
sur les sociétés c'est ce qui se passe
c'est à Paris de politique publique que
nous faisons et qui que ce soit qui nous
remplace
qui nous remplacent pas aux fonctions
devra faire lui-même des paris
politiques dans un sens ou dans l'autre
il n'y a pas de certitude absolue dans
une politique économique ça n'existe pas
je pense que le gouvernement a raison de
dire qu'il faut à la fois des recettes
supplémentaires et sur des recettes qui
sont cohérentes avec nos objectifs de
transition écologique parce que soyons
très clair il y a une question de
cohérence avec nos ambitions transit
écologiques et sur celle de l’équitif
fiscale il y aura cette année une mesure
très importante qui va ramener de
l'argent dans les caisses de l'État
c'est la peau universel sur les
entreprises c'est quelque chose sur
lequel le président de la République et
le ministre de l'économie se sont battus
sans relâche à l'OCDE pendant 5 ans et
bah cette année il y a 1,15 milliards à
peu près qui rentreront dans les caisses
d'états parce que toutes les sociétés
seront à poser au pilier de l'accord de
l'OCDE ça c'est une mesure majeure
majeure qui répond à une demande majeure
des Français il faut des recettes
supplémentaires et elles sont là après
et là je rejoins un peu ce que Patricia
au début nous avons des efforts très
considérables à faire dans les années
qui suivent il faut pas se voiler la
face c'est une évidence c'est-à-dire
l'année d'après dans les années à tout
de suite dans les années
convaincue par ce raisonnement ou pas il
y a une part de risques mais c'est vrai
que l'activité économique elle est là
non mais la France l'Allemagne en mieux
titres tant mieux tant mieux ça c'est le
volet positif mais là où je ne suis
absolument pas d'accord avec les choix
qui sont faits par
Monsieur le Maire c'est le fait de
procrastiner d'ailleurs tout le monde le
dit aujourd'hui ça c'est très dangereux
et en fait je voudrais simplement
revenir sur un point sur lequel entre le
discours du mois de juin et aujourd'hui
il y a un écart énorme prenez par
exemple je suis élu alsacien et donc
l'Allemagne est à nos portes prenez la
situation dans les hôpitaux dans les
hôpitaux en Allemagne sur 100 personnel
85 soignants 15 personnels
administratifs chez nous 25 personnels
administratifs 75 soignants tout est dit
c'est-à-dire que en éviter cette
bureaucratisation d'un certain nombre de
nos de nos services publics nous sommes
supprimés des postes fonctionnaires dans
quel secteur précisément la santé
l'administration de la santé il faut
déployer différemment les emplois il
s'agit pas forcément de les supprimer
mais de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
les redéployer en l'occurrence il faut
faire bouger les lignes de telle sorte
que au lieu d'être à 75 soignants on
puisse monter progressivement parce que
de surcroît ces administrations par
exemple hospitalières contribuent à
créer une chape de plomb vis-à-vis du
personnel soignant avec des lourdeurs
des
en essayant de résoudre la crise de
l'hôpital mais bien sûr puisque en
réalité la première crise de l'hôpital
c'est que les soignants aujourd'hui sont
à bout parce qu'ils s'occupent de plus
en plus d'administration et de moins en
moins de soins c'est un exemple mais il
y en a beaucoup d'autres alors l'autre
sujet qui me tient à cœur je veux pas
être trop long sur ce sujet un moment
donné
j'ai présidé une commission d'enquête il
y a trois ans sur les fraudes sociales
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'un certain
nombre de ces fraudes se font en bande
organisées ça fait trois ans que nous
réclamons le passage à une ordonnance
dématérialisée vous l'Espagne l'a fait
en faisant cela la première année plus
d'un demi milliard d'économies à travers
simplement le fait qu'il n'y ait un
million vous allez travailler sur la
fraude sociale marvinho
comment dire
réellement où on est un peu dans
prescription oui c'est un des gisements
d'économie à faire sur sur la fraude
sociale après il ne faut pas surestimer
le sujet de la preuve sociale pour
redressement des comptes publics et en
plus la fraude sociale n'est pas souvent
pas là où on croit c'est-à-dire que il y
a beaucoup par exemple de fraudes chez
les infirmiers libéraux parce que ils
surfacture en fait le fraudeur
individuel qui serait organisé pour
voler la sécu c'est pas c'est pas des
sommes qui sont l'échelle de la
réduction du déficit et de la dette
évidemment ça existe il faut être le
plus dur possible et d'ailleurs il y a
des il y a un plan là qui est en cours
d'évaluations de la fraude fiscale et
sociale qui va être mis sur pied pour
faire une évaluation officielle de ce
que coûte la fraude en France parce que
on se lance tous des chiffres un peu
pas forcément très fondé à la tête la
gauche ainsi sur la fraude fiscale la
droite ainsi sur la fosse sociale et
personne n'est d'accord et au final on
manque d'une évaluation crédible mais il
faut pas surestimer le sujet de la
fraude par exemple carte vitale qui a
été largement déjà ça a été assénible le
système a été assaini et on voit bien
que ça n'a pas fait beaucoup d'argent
dans laquelle une partie de la fraude
sociale la fonction publique
hospitalière et vous à gauche et puis on
demandera ensuite l'arbitre rage de
François et cale où vous trouvez des
économies déjà on peut trouver de
l'argent en gérant mieux sa dette
aujourd'hui on a un problème c'est que
la dette on l'a on lève de la dette en
sur l'inflation l'index la dette sur
l'inflation ça veut dire que en gros je
vous achète enfin vous m'achetez un peu
de dette et ma dette elle va exploser
parce que l'inflation explose et ça le
gouvernement de façon irresponsable
continue à emprunter de la dette indexée
sur l'inflation donc ça ça coûte allez 5
6 milliards par an premier sujet juste
de bonnes gestion
c'est un choix progressivement
aujourd'hui on continue le contraire
même à continuer à le sujet comme
celui-là ça c'est un premier jugé de de
gisement deuxième sujet c'est que oui on
doit réfléchir à la question je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure un budget c'est des
recettes et des dépenses aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a fait énormément de
cadeaux depuis 2017 au plus fortuné avec
la flat tax avec la suppression de l'ISF
tout ça c'est des milliards d'euros qui
ont été
ont disparu
c'est ça que vous l'avez par exemple le
capital à la hauteur de ce qu'il était
avant donc là vous revenez sur la
politique économique ça ça rapporte les
entreprises
de milliards d'euros on voit bien ce que
ça a perdu ce qu'on a perdu quand on a
instauré la flat tax c'est pas du tout
une dizaine de milliards je finis
j'étais sur la fenêtre tax mais je
disais on réinstant aussi une entreprise
yesf c'était le delta c'est à peu près 3
milliards d'euros entre l'ISF et la
nouvelle version avec les filles ça
c'est des choses qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui on remet aussi autre chose
la taxe sur les super profits qui
annoncé par le gouvernement c'est à peu
près 600 millions d'euros nous la taxe
qu'on défend de l'Europe
c'est à peu près allez 2 3 4 milliards
d'euros mais c'est parce qu'on est un
peu plus ambitieux avec des gens qui
font des supers profits de façon
conséquente donc sur on n'a pas mis la
question on a la question
autoroutière la question des
énergéticiens on a la question des
transporteurs maritimes c'est ma CGM par
exemple qui est un grand groupe donc
voilà on n'a pas été assez ambitieux sur
la question la taxe sur les super
profits ça c'est des recettes
supplémentaires il y a beaucoup de
choses il faut faire réagir oui voyez
vous dites quels sont vos leviers moi
je réponds aussi sur la question de
l'hôpital public il faut arrêter de dire
que c'est en supprimant quelques postes
de fonctionnaires dans la gestion
administrative qu'on va régler la crise
de l'hôpital public ou qu'on va
permettre de répondre ce qu'il faut
c'est au contraire investir de la santé
parce que ça rapporte de l'argent ça
permet que quand les gens ils sont en
meilleure santé et ben ils travaillent
plus il y a moins d'arrêt maladie enfin
bref il y a tout un travail aussi à
faire autour de la prévention c'est le
sujet et ça c'est de l'investissement
qui rapporte d'un sud
très clairement deux parties pris
politiques très différents qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez en tant que spécialiste
des finances publiques et aussi soucieux
de la situation la bonne santé
économique du pays je pense qu'il faut
en effet réduire le déficit public pour
reprendre le contrôle de la date parce
que sinon on risque un jour d'avoir des
ennuis je ne sais pas quand personne ne
sait quand ça peut arriver à n'importe
quel moment et ce jour-là parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de l'Italie
heureusement je dirais pour nous il y a
les Italiens qui sont dans une situation
plus grave
public beaucoup plus élevé un déficit
beaucoup plus élevé et en ce moment
d'ailleurs ça va mal parce que l'Italie
l'Italie vient d'annoncer que son
déficit serait beaucoup plus importante
que ce qui était prévu aujourd'hui les
marchés le taux d'intérêt sur les
obligations italiennes est en train de
monter et là on a deux options on a
clairement ce qu'on appelle la justice
fiscale les plus riches les entreprises
et puis la fonction publique et les
questions de fraude alors pour résoudre
ce problème on peut en effet augmenter
les impôts mais comme vous le rappeliez
tout à l'heure on est déjà les numéros 1
ou les numéros 2 en matière de
prélèvement obligatoire alors on peut
toujours les augmenter un peu plus mais
je pense que si on a c'est pareil on ne
sait pas quel est le taux maximal des
prélèvements obligatoires mais moi je
pense que si on a des taux qui sont
nettement supérieurs à ceux de nos
voisins et concurrents ont fini par
avoir des problèmes d'attractivité du
territoire et de compétitivité et ces
problèmes on les a déjà on a un déficit
extérieur qui vient quand même très
largement systématique qui vient
largement du fait que finalement quelque
part on a des entreprises qui ont des
produits avec un rapport qualité coût
qui est insuffisant
le mot de la fin Alexandre j'aimerais
bien que vous me répondiez je vous
reposerais la question sur Vinci parce
que je suis sûr que ça intéresse nos
téléspectateurs mais là on voit bien que
il y a une un retour des taxes super
profits entreprises à gauche mais dans
votre propre camp également le modem met
en avant c'est nouveaux amendements sur
les super profits même sur les
dividendes vous êtes ouvert ou c'est
déjà fermé le débat la discussion vous
savez ça fait 40 ans que des
responsables politiques français pensent
qu'en assénant les Français de plus
d'impôts on va sortir du problème du
défi et dette et l'arrivée c'est que ça
fait 40 ans que ça ne marche pas tous
les Français qui la réalité la réalité
c'est que aujourd'hui on est le deuxième
pays de CD ou le premier bonhomme allant
avec le Danemark qui a une dette
publique qui a décidé de publique qui
est dans un autre monde que l'autre et
qui taxe le plus c'est concitoyens et
ses entreprises et qu'on n'arrive pas à
le rétraction après
il est évident que dans les pertes dans
la grande période de transition et
notamment pour le financement de la
transition écologique qu'on arrivait il
va falloir faire des modifications
fiscales ce qui ne veut pas dire une
augmentation du taux de prélève
obligatoire c'est à dire l'intégralité
de la fiscalité qui est posée sur les
Français je pense que c'est essentiel
qu'on regarde les choses comme ça c'est
à dire qu'on regarde notre modèle social
et on dit notre modèle social il est
formidable il est fabuleux il faut le
financer mais aujourd'hui on prélève
beaucoup plus nos concitoyens et
beaucoup plus nos entreprises avec dans
certaines politiques publiques des
résultats qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
et là il y a un travail à faire
présidentiel c'est pour une campagne
à la fin Vinci allez je demande
peut-être à marvinho vous vous avez la
réponse merci pour empêcher Vinci
d'augmenter les tarifs au péage je suis
pas spécialiste de sujet j'ai pas
regardé en détail mais le gouvernement a
demandé un avis au Conseil d'État il y a
eu un débat interne au gouvernement
Clément Baule le ministre des Transports
était plutôt favorable à cette taxe
Bruno Le Maire a plutôt résisté et au
final ils ont trouvé que c'était
possible alors je ne sais pas si ça sera
exact mais a priori ils se disent qu'il
y a un moyen de de passer et le
politique ou l'économique c'est un débat
important même sur ces questions là de
péage on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
c'était beaucoup plus clair en tous les
cas merci d'être venu débattre en direct
sur SCP vous restez avec moi Arthur de
la porte dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties prit de nos affranchis ce soir
la politique avec Yael Goose et si
Emmanuel Macron avait perdu le goût du
risque le mot de la semaine de Mariotte
darriggan c'est une expression plutôt à
la française comme l'écologie voulue par
notre président et puis d'un bonbon
Express ce soir de quoi nous parler vous
Marco pommier et ben ce on va parler de
la séance des questions au gouvernement
les questions d'un toilettage à tout de
suite les amis mais d'abord on va parler
de voitures de la porte et de votre
petit mammifeste un petit livre pour un
socialisme joyeux aux Éditions de l'Aube
ça peut sembler un peu naïf comme ça au
vu de la crise que traverse votre partie
mais vous vous assumez le militantisme
du parti de François Mitterrand doit
retrouver le sens de la fête regardez
c'est dans l'invitation d'Hélène
Bonduelle on en parle tous les deux
juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite Arthur de la porte
c'est pour lutter contre la sinistrose
ambiante
le patron du Parti communiste nous
promet des jours heureux vous vous
pariez sur un socialisme joyeux c'est
l'objet de votre essai une plongée dans
les arcanes du militantisme socialiste
il y aurait-il un retour en grâce des
émotions en politique en tout cas pour
vous porte-parole du groupe socialiste
et apparentés à l'Assemblée nationale
seule la joie doit être porteuse de
transformation sociale l'indination ne
suffirait donc plus vous allez créer des
pauvres vous allez mettre des gens dans
la rue ils n'auront même plus le RSA
pour survivre vous en serez responsable
[Musique]
père français et bien sûr l'inflation
nous ne pouvions pas laisser la parole
du peuple seulement entre les mains de
Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
le socialisme un parti qui a perdu trois
quarts de ses adhérents en 11 ans
peut-il encore susciter l'envie un parti
déserté dans une alliance la nupesse qui
se fracture l'associal démocratie n'est
plus un logiciel politique susceptible
de fonctionner pour le 21e siècle alors
je dis à mes amis sociaux-démocrates il
faut réviser votre affaire alors nous
avons une question pour vous Arthur de
la porte face à la stratégie du bruit et
de la fureur le militantisme joyeux que
vous prenez n'est-il pas un peu
utopique
réponse à Arthur de la porte une bonne
question moi je pense que quand on fait
de la politique on s'engage aussi parce
qu'on veut porter un espoir parce qu'on
veut quelque chose de différent et donc
si on dit ah bah non moi je vous propose
un socialisme triste je suis pas sûr que
c'est comme ça qui que vous allez
convaincre les gens de voter pour vous
et ça je parle de manière générale en
politique mais c'est vrai que c'est
aussi un moyen de dire il faut arrêter
l'autophagie d'action parce que sinon on
arrivera jamais à repartir du bon pied
alors dans ce livre co-écrit avec Sarah
kerrich vous racontez la descente aux
enfers de la gauche la désertion des
militants la spirale des différents
défaites et vous l'expliquez surtout par
l'absence de récits politiques vous
dites que au fond le PS a perdu le sens
du roman national n'a pas su expliquer
où il voulait emmener les Françaises
qu'il est rassemblé depuis quand le PS a
perdu ça je pense que c'est une
transformation qui s'est faite sur le
temps long c'est pas forcément la
question du roman national au sens
strict mais c'est juste la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on projette comme horizon
désirable d'ailleurs c'était l'une des
intuitions de Benoît Hamon la campagne
de 2017 c'est-à-dire comment on arrive à
créer un futur désirable qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on se projette ensemble et ça
nous on propose la joie comme un liant
un facteur quelque chose qui fait qu'on
a envie d'être ensemble et qu'on n'est
pas simplement des individus isolés les
uns des autres et ça c'est vrai que ça a
fait partie de ce qu'il y a ce qui a
suscité le début de notre réflexion avec
Sarah qui riche donc a écrit ce livre
avec moi c'était de se dire bon on a
fait des campagnes joyeuses on a militée
ensemble de façon joyeuse ça a marché
notamment ma campagne législative
c'était une campagne très très
sympathique très dynamique etc on se dit
mais comment ça se fait que on croise
tellement de gens qui disent ah bah ça
doit pas être facile de payer ça alors
que enfin nous on vit notre engagement
comme quelque chose qui doit être
positif alors vous voulez aussi
retrouver l'esprit festif au sein du
parti donc de la bataille des retraites
que vous avez partagées avec vos
collègues de la nuque dans les cortèges
c'est vraiment un moment comment dire de
ferveur militante qui s'est passé
vraiment c'est vrai que ce qu'on observe
ces derniers mois c'est qu'il y a une
remobilisation citoyenne il y a eu le
moment des retraites et moi je raconte
quelque chose qui m'a fortement marqué
c'était un moment dans un cortège
parisien un après-midi on s'est échappé
de l'Assemblée nationale et il y avait
en effet ce stand de d'alternatiba où il
y avait une sono et les gens criait
chanter danser derrière ce cortège un
peu une ambiance Techno Parade mais très
militante et très on va dire très
entraînante et on avait juste envie
d'une chose c'était de se jeter dans ce
cortège avec tous ces jeunes mobilisent
aujourd'hui on retrouve justement cet
engagement cette ferveur sur des grands
thèmes de mobilisation ça peut être le
climat les sujets sociaux beaucoup plus
que les parties ça vous en convenait
alors c'est juste parce qu'il faut
changer en général les organisations
qui a perdu des adhérents ces dernières
années on peut regarder LR qui s'est
réduit à peau de chagrin mais même des
parties de masse comme le Parti
communiste aujourd'hui ont des effectifs
qui approchent ou sont un peu
inférieures à ceux du Parti socialiste
alors qu'ils ont été longtemps à 300 400
500 000 adhérents mais pourquoi vous y
êtes restés à part le fait parce que je
le précise que vous avez ce qu'on
appelle une circonscription socialiste
en or massif vous êtes dans la cinquième
du Calvados la deuxième pardon ça fait
j'ai calculé ça 40 ans que le PS gagne
les élections dans cette là 2002 à 2007
c'est pour ça que vous êtes resté alors
non je suis pas resté pour ça parce que
finalement moi quand je suis resté au PS
au moment du de la vague de départ entre
2015 et 2017 c'est là où le parti
socialiste a perdu en gros deux tiers de
ces adhérents je suis resté parce que je
croyais dans les valeurs du socialisme
il y avait aussi tous ceux qui
accusaient le parti d'avoir trahis-mer
et je ne dis pas que le parti n'a pas
trahi ces valeurs justement pourquoi les
gens ont arrêté un moment de se dire le
Parti socialiste c'est la solution
c'était aussi parce que on avait fait la
loi travail et la déchéance du
nationalité c'est à dire deux choses qui
pour moi étaient antagonistes par
rapport à ce que doit être le socialisme
et je suis resté parce que je me suis
dit je voyais pas d'ailleurs je voyais
pas d'options dans Emmanuel Macron et je
me sentais fidèle à cet héritage
j'aurais sien de Léon Blum et il y a que
dans le Parti socialiste qu'on pouvait
trouver en fait cette
issue mais alors comment on retrouve au
fond ce sens de la joie politique comme
une force qui on pense aux militantisme
de l'après-guerre on pense au
syndicalisme dans les usines aussi en
1936 mais c'est très très loin ça
regardait quelques images la fête on l'a
fait souvent partie socialiste on a
retrouvé les fameuses fêtes de la Rose
vous souvenez d'Arnaud Montebourg bon ça
lui a pas forcément bien réussi cette
cuvée du redressement mais c'est ça les
images des fêtes politiques c'est
beaucoup un peu de la communication on
sent bien que on fait ça pour les
caméras non c'est pas de la com parce
que ce qui se passait et ce qui se passe
toujours aux parties socialiste c'est
qu'il y a plein de fêtes partout toutes
les semaines tous les week-ends là par
exemple le week-end prochain vous pouvez
avoir une fête dans le Finistère vous
pouvez avoir une fête
alors quand on est socialiste on se
retrouve ensemble déjà on a plaisir à
être ensemble ça c'est quelque chose qui
reste c'est on mange ensemble on chante
ensemble on ensemble et ça ça soude une
communauté militante c'est pour ça que
on peut pas finalement se réduire
jusqu'au bout parce qu'il y a des gens
qui ont plaisir à être ensemble et à
mener des combats ensemble mais ce qui
est vrai c'est que l'organisation elle
doit se transformer c'est pas
satisfaisant aujourd'hui c'est une
désorganisation politique de manière
générale ils sont vieillissantes et donc
qui sont pas dans un mixage social très
très grand il y a beaucoup de produits
vous avez des partis qui sont clairement
des parties de CSP+ en marche par
exemple la sociologie en marche c'est
clairement un parti de CSP+ vous avez
des parties comme le Parti communiste le
Parti socialiste où vous avez encore un
noyau de militants populaires le
problème c'est derrière comment on fait
en sorte que ces militants qui sont de
milieu populaire accèdent aux
responsabilités parce que le sujet il
est là il est que on peut être un
militant populaire et rester un militant
populaire mais le problème c'est que
derrière les cadres finalement
c'était d'être des instances de
formation et et si on regarde la
sociologie des parties il faut arrêter
aussi de dire que les parties se sont
totalement coupées des milieux
populaires parce que dans le Calvados
par exemple moi il y a beaucoup
d'adhérents du Parti socialiste qui sont
issus des classes populaires et je suis
fier de militer avec eux et qui soit et
qu'on soit tous ensemble et par ailleurs
moi je viens pas de la grande
bourgeoisie voilà je suis on va dire la
classe moyenne intermédiaire issue de
cette caisse là et je pense que on a
aussi cette capacité à être un parti
divers une école de formation
d'émancipation pour vous très important
pour moi oui alors être ensemble vous
étiez à la nuit pour voir trouver cette
cette photo de de 2022 cette grande
alliance électorale où là on avait
l'impression que vous l'aviez un peu ce
sens de la de la fête l'envie d'être
ensemble bon c'est fini tout ça on est
on est aujourd'hui plus que jamais dans
la division voire même dans la violence
ce qui est vrai non moi je refuse de de
participer à ceux qui disent la nuque
s'est divisée la nuque c'est fini quand
vous avez quand même une alliance qui
compare Fabien Roussel et je parle de
Sophia Chikirou à doriaux c'est de la
violence c'est une intensité
acceptable etc mais voilà moi je suis
capable de parler très bien avec les uns
et les autres et j'ai pas de problème à
dire que on a un objectif commun c'est
de faire une alternance en 2010 je ne
les aime pas ça c'est ça responsabilité
moi je suis pas dans une agressivité je
pense que ce qu'attendent les Français
de la gauche c'est d'être assez
responsable pour s'unir en vue de la
présidentielle parce qu'il faut être en
capacité de porter une alternative en
vue de la présidentielle en attendant la
Nupe c'est une forme d'alliance
électorale pour les législatives mais
surtout regardez toutes les autres
élections jusqu'au présidentielles on
verra vous faites cavalier seul chacun
dans votre coin parce que c'est plus
efficace et lectoralement alors il y a
d'un côté les élections leur modalités
leur modalités municipales les
municipales il y aura des alliances de
toute la gauche moi j'ai été candidat au
départemental dans le Calvados sur une
liste d'union de la gauche avec le
soutien des Verts des communistes etc
donc non on est capable de s'unir et
même au Parlement parce que je suis
député là toute la journée j'étais dans
l'hémicycle sur le RSA à batailler mais
de manière extrêmement concordante avec
mes camarades communistes écologistes et
insoumis et membre de génération faut
pas obliger de génération bref on est
tous soudés et on avance avec optimisme
et avec aussi cette joie parce que la
joie et j'y reviens c'est une manière
d'être au sein du parti mais c'est aussi
une manière d'être avec les gens je veux
dire il faut être Olivier fort il est
dans la joie il incarne aujourd'hui un
parti socialiste coupé en deux le
dernier congrès franchement était très
très violent il y a deux lignes on la
voit au Sénat cette ligne Olivier fort
moi je le pratique au quotidien et je me
souviens d'un de ses proches il me dit
tu verras Olivier c'est une crème c'est
vrai que il y a cette idée de la
bienveillance de ce rapport à l'autre et
c'est que comme ça que on va attirer des
gens à nous c'est en étant positif et
moi j'essaie d'être toujours dans cette
optimisme permanent et je suis pas le
seul enfin déjà on est au moins deux
avec Sara gris parce qu'on a écrit ce
livre ensemble mais on se retrouve et je
peux vous dire que les retours des
militants ce livre c’est vrai ça fait du
bien alors je vais pas dire c'est un
feel good bouquin pour les militants
mais il y a ce côté oui ça peut être
positif d'être socialiste c'est positif
de faire de la politique et plus
largement parce que c'est positif de
s'engager en politique quel que soit le
parti parce qu'on va défendre ses
convictions ses valeurs et trouver des
gens qui les partagent on entend un
accent sincérité Arthur de la porte pour
un socialisme joyeux c'est donc coécrit
aux Éditions de l'Aube avec Sarah Kerris
vous restez avec moi c'est leur des
partis pris de nos affranchir et vous
vous faire réagir Arthur de la porte on
les accueille tout de suite
il y a le Goose de France Inter
éditorialiste politique et chef du
service installé vous et puis la
sémiologue du vendredi normalement
Mariette mais on est ravi de vous
accueillir ce soir pour votre mot de la
semaine bienvenue à vous on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous qui nous l'a racontez Marco pommier
bonsoir à vous bonsoir Myriam ce soir je
vous raconte l'histoire d'un rendez-vous
incontournable de l'Assemblée la séance
de questions au gouvernement il y a le
brun Pivet veut réformer cette séance de
questions au gouvernement les fameuses
Q âgées s'échappent mardi à 15h sur LCP
des députés qui interpellent les
ministres sur des sujets d'actualité et
c'est l'occasion aussi pour certains et
bah de se faire remarquer avec des coups
d'éclats des jeux de mots ça va m'en
préparer pour faire mouche ça dure deux
heures mais chaque mardi plus la séance
passe moins il y a de monde
on perd en gros 50% de tout c'est à dire
que je perds 50% de députés dans
l'hémicycle je perds 50% de ministres et
je perds 50% de téléspectateurs
et les images de mardi dernier donne
raison à Gaëlle privé regardez à 15h19
minutes exactement après le début à des
questions gouvernement les mystiques est
bien remplie une heure et demie plus
tard bah c'est plus la même histoire il
y a plus grand monde sur les bancs alors
pourquoi cette désertion et ben on est
allé poser la question
il y a une désinfection pour les
questions au Gouvernement une sorte
d'exercice de style un peu un peu
suranné qui a besoin de redynamiser tout
ça c'est pas que la faute du format des
questions gouvernement c'est surtout que
le gouvernement ne répond plus jamais
aux questions c'est-à-dire que quand
c'est pas une question
de la majorité il y a rarement
une réponse donc non seulement il y a
pas de réponse si vous voulez deux
heures de blabla de Madame borne et de
ses et de de sa bande à neuneuse c'est
un peu long vous voyez très bien que
c'est un jeu d'acteurs finalement on
pose une question et il suffit d'aller
voir ce qu'en font et bien ceux qui pose
la question on ne lui jamais la réponse
du ministre bon voilà en quelque soit le
groupe on n'est pas vraiment fan du
format actuel dont l'opposition au
pointe du doigt aussi le style borne
trop monocorde selon certains un
insoumis à me disait hier Elisabeth
borne elle enterre tout le monde il
n'empêche Myriam beaucoup de députés
défendent ce moment fort de la vie
démocratique et indispensable au
contrôle de l'action de l'action du
gouvernement pardon alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle veut faire il y a El Brown privé
pour changer un peu ce rendez-vous et
bien veut redynamiser les échanges 4
pistes sont sur la sur son sur la table
ramener le nombre de questions de 28 à
21 exiger des réponses plus courtes une
minute 30 contre 2 minutes aujourd'hui
c'est des propositions elles
permettraient bien de gagner 30 minutes
sur la séance autre piste attribuer un
temps de parole global à chaque groupe
ou alors revenir à deux séances de
questions par semaine c'était le cas
avant 2019 mais cette fois ça serait
dans un format renouvelé qui reste
encore bien flou proposition et bien qui
suscite des réactions le député il porte
lui-même sa sa voix donc je pense qu'il
faut toujours garder les deux minutes
mais par contre on abaisse le nombre de
questions pour que ça dure un peu moins
longtemps tout ce qui viserait à réduire
le temps de interpellation des ministres
ou réduire les moments on peut
interpellé c'est non voilà pas évident
de s'accorder sur une nouvelle formule
il y a LeBron pivée veut pourtant un
consensus sur la question elle réunira
dès mercredi prochain les présidents de
groupe pour en parler on verra ce que ça
donne ceci pénible que ça c'est vrai que
cette longue séance de questions je vous
assure que quand vous êtes à votre place
à écouter des questions assez convenues
pour beaucoup et des réponses encore
plus convenues pour l'essentiel c'est
assez pénible et je me mets à la place
des spectateurs qui regardent ça sur LCP
en exclusivité je me dis qu'ils doivent
parfois trouver ton nom même si il y a
toujours un intérêt je trouve du grand
public
et c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui est ancré finalement dans cette
histoire politique française depuis le
début c'est là qu'on a commencé à voir
l'Assemblée nationale en direct à la
télé alors à l'époque c'était sur France
3 je crois moi c'est comme ça que j'ai
découvert l'Assemblée nationale et c'est
vrai que c'est un premier contact donc
c'est important de maintenir ce
rendez-vous et bon on peut dire que
aujourd'hui elle se rend compte que a
fait une erreur parce que c'est Richard
Ferrand qui a fait ces questions sur
deux heures et non plus sur deux jours
avec un argument à l'époque qui était
quand même de dire ça n'a plus d'intérêt
il y a une désertion le mercredi etc
donc les arguments étaient à peu près
les mêmes mais il faut se faire
attention à une chose c'est que si on
réduit trop les taux de positions elles
n'auront plus d'espace de questionnement
parce que quand on est aux questions
gouvernement on peut poser une question
au ministre sur n'importe quel sujet et
donc peut-être qu'on pourrait simplement
supprimer les questions de la majorité
parce qu'après les ministres connaissent
déjà des questions et des réponses je
sens que cette proposition va rencontrer
beaucoup de soutiens Merci à VOUS Arthur
de la porte vous allez réagir à elle
Goose à présent ils sont partis pris
planification écologique c'était un des
grands rendez-vous cette semaine
d'Emmanuel Macron la semaine dernière en
fin de semaine dernière fin de vie
fiscalité vous nous dites que la rentrée
d'Emmanuel Macron est bien trop prudente
et c'est la funeste malédiction des
calendriers politiques plus on
s'approche de 2027 et plus l'émetteur
Macron va perdre en puissance en
influence à mesure qu'il sera
concurrencée que la campagne pour sa
succession va commencer autrement dit
c'est maintenant et jusqu'aux
européennes qui auront des allures de
mitter d'élections mimanda c'est
maintenant qu'il faut enfourcher le
tigre pour reprendre son expression
fétiche du temps du covid mais c'est
parce qu'il a fait selon vous depuis la
rentrée non c'est comme s'il était
régulièrement sur les freins de peur de
faire le jeu de Marine Le Pen à force de
ne pas vouloir emmerder les Français
Macron Pompidou se prive de souffle
lui-même comme si toute sa politique
était irriguée par le principe de
précaution anti RN les retraites sont
passées donc plus de vagues pas de
vagues la réforme oui seulement si elle
est populaire vous voulez peut-être des
exemples absolument dans son écologie à
la française la bagnole est toujours
reine mais en leasing électrique voilà
le progrès technologique passe devant la
sobriété qui doit rester mesurée cette
sobriété et les éoliennes terrestres on
en parle plus sur le budget
arrow sur la moindre taxe pas de taxe
qui dépasse pas touche au tabac pas
touche au vin pas touche aux alcools une
campagne de prévention en plein mondiale
du rugby non merci et d'ailleurs celle
qui vient de sortir vous avez peut-être
vu et qui cible les jeunes est un monde
un modèle de non culpabilisation qui
frise le ridicule il y a une des
affiches je vous la lis pensez à manger
avant de boire de l'alcool c'est la base
donc on mange et puis on picole sympa le
message et puis sur le projet de loi fin
de vie on est toujours dans l'attente et
quand Emmanuel Macron temporise c'est
mauvais signe c'est qu'il est mal à
l'aise alors qu'est-ce qu'il devrait
faire sur vous bah assumer monter le
volume nous dire les choses franchement
puisqu'il n'a plus rien à perdre
électoralement parlant nous dire que la
transition écologique exigera de gros
efforts et ça on est capable de le
comprendre où les Français on a réussi à
relever le défi de la sobriété l'année
dernière arrêtez de céder aussi au lobby
de l'alcool ou du vin si la drogue c'est
de la merde alors l'alcool aussi c'est
une question de santé publique trancher
la question de la fin de vie ça n'a que
trop duré et la convention citoyenne a
déjà rendu ses conclusions en avril
dernier le synchronisme à l'origine
c'était le dépassement permanent
aujourd'hui manuel Macron doit dépasser
le dépassement maintenant que son compte
à rebours personnel a commencé il doit
dépasser le dépassement faire moins dans
la nuance peut-être mais pour laisser
plus de traces et l'histoire jugera
d'accord avec ça il faut qu'il y a le
franchissement maintenant il y a plus
rien à perdre c'est à dire que si c'est
pour aller avec la droite qu'il y aille
moi je ne le suivrai pas par contre si
c'est pour dire bon je vais enfin faire
une transition écologique ambitieuse
arrêtez de faire de la petite mesurée
parce que son sa grande annonce de lundi
dernier sur un plan massif pour la
transition énergétique il y avait rien
du tout c'était trois climatiseurs
par-ci et une pompe à chaleur par là
sachant que il y avait rien pour la
rénovation des logements il y avait 900
millions où je sais pas ou 700 millions
pour le train il faudrait des milliards
donc vous voyez il y a rien qui à la
hauteur il y a rien qui est finalement
assez ambitieux et là où je vous suis
mais j'irai un peu plus loin c'est que
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas simplement
qu'il veut pas c'est qui cède au lobby
parce que oui la question de l'alcool la
question du tabac la question même de la
voiture derrière il y a des lobbies il y
a énormément qui est en jeu il y a des
gens qui ont leurs accès à l'Élysée et
qui lui disent attention surtout on
bouge pas alors là sur l'alcool c'est
sûr je pense pas qu'il y a une peur de
la taxation de l'alcool qui conduisent à
une augmentation du voltérine ça c'est
pas vrai y a-t-il longtemps conseillé
par une responsable de la filière
viticole Audrey bourroulaud à l'Elysée
c'est un peu
de cette chronique de Yaël Goz c'est pas
un mot de la semaine c'est une
expression de la semaine on le disait à
la française la fameuse écologie à la
française voulue par Emmanuel Macron oui
alors ça m'a alerté ça m'a intéressé
cette formule là parce que d'habitude
elle est dans un contexte beaucoup plus
léger on parle de jardin la française de
gastronomie à la française de haute
couture à la française donc qu'est-ce
que ça vient faire dans la politique ça
je me suis demandé parce que c'est tout
à fait intéressant je crois que c'est
assez prometteur en fait c'est vrai
qu'il y a un petit côté frivole à cette
expression pas exactement mais n'oubliez
pas Myriam qu'on était après le dîner
royal à Versailles dans un contexte bon
et là la galerie des Glaces le jardin à
la française de le nôtre qui n'est pas
du tout un jardin anglais donc je crois
qu'il y a eu un côté comme ça
classicisme 17e donc Emmanuel Macron il
voulait nous dire que nous sous nos
cieux hédonistes évidemment dans un pays
qui a inventé la gastronomie le
champagne et la philosophie dans le
salon dans le boudoir on ne pouvait pas
être punitif donc ça c'était
tout à fait tout à fait clair et ça
s'opposait aux écologies supposées
austères des pays scandinaves ou
anglossaques sont alors c'est vrai que
chez nous il y a toujours un petit côté
frontières un petit côté libre un petit
côté bagnole il faut bien le dire comme
Emmanuel Macron on l'a dit c'est ça qui
voulait rappeler le Président je pense
qu'à la française première couche c'est
le plaisir et vous allez me coucher la
liberté chez nous c'est une valeur
sacrée la liberté guide toujours le
peuple ou proue donc voilà les deux
pivots de cette expression mais il y en
a une troisième et je ne sais pas si le
chef de l'État l'avait en tête mais je
pense que c'est pour nous qui
réfléchissons à la démocratie à la
française éventuelle et ben le plus
intéressant alors là on est plus dans
l'histoire longue on est dans l'histoire
contemporaine parce que à la française
est un énoncé qui a été recolorisé
dernièrement par l'industrie de la mode
du luxe de la de l'art contemporain et
avec beaucoup de succès comme vous le
savez parce que c'est une industrie
lourde aujourd'hui dans notre économie
alors c'est tout à fait intéressant
parce que quand un acheteur asiatique
quelqu'un ou quelqu'un du golf entend à
la française ou à la française parce que
c'est pas traduit à la française
exactement tout de suite il voit haute
qualité il voit histoire il voit
artisanat vraiment de d'extrêmement etc
donc c'est quand même très intéressant
et aussi dimension nouvelle hybridation
avec d'autres cultures voilà alors je ne
dis pas que au moment où la France se
paupérise il faut faire du luxe à tous
les étages c'est pas ça en revanche
c'est un modèle très intéressant si on
veut à la fois comme disait Paul Ricker
magnifiquement
fertiliser notre immense héritage en
innovant c'est ça qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui donc je rêve un peu une
démocratie à la française pour moi ce
serait et justement une manière pour je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que il
y a elle disait ce serait une manière de
s'engager beaucoup plus et de nous dire
ben voilà nous sommes fiers de quelque
chose nous avons une histoire et nous
savons très bien ce que nous pouvons
faire ensemble ça me semble beaucoup
plus fort que la start-up nation par
exemple et ben voilà un beau parti pris
très complémentaire d'un mot minuscule
réaction vraiment moi si c'est
l'écologie à la française ça veut dire
pas d'écologie du tout parce que pour
l'instant on n'en voit pas la couleur je
trouve que ça ne va pas si c'est un
moyen de dire on va continuer à dépenser
à faire n'importe quoi et à ne pas
s'engager dans la sobriété parce qu'il
en faut c'est
l'itinéraire de ce mot de ses origines à
son évocation à nos imaginaires c'est
toujours passionnant avec vous Mariette
à jeudi prochain il y a elle on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à très
vite bien sûr Marco Merci à VOUS Arthur
de la porte pour un socialisme joyeux à
demain très belle soirée sur SCP
[Musique]